someone has actually never seen anything
that either of you have done what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
i think friday night lights because it
was where i
really fell in love with acting in a
different way
and
it was the first time i really felt like
i got to
fully invest my myself in the character
and take ownership of it and we
improvised a lot and then
and then i sort of grew with that
character so that would be a
decent place to start
i i would say it's not the easiest to
watch perhaps but i would probably say
to the bone just in that it was the most
um
weirdly freeing as well as difficult as
well as a
meta type of experience for me as an
artist and as a human being and i think
it was a character i felt very close to
and i the message of the movie was one
in which i felt was really important to
bring to more people because it's a
subject matter that a lot of people have
a lot of shame uh surrounding and don't
speak about enough so i think that would
probably be
um
the first thing that comes to mind but
then i'd say like then watch emily to
laugh because otherwise it's just you
know you don't want to just stay in that
storyline too long
uh jumping into why i get to talk to you
guys i really want to start with
congrats i watched the movie last night
it's real good and you guys are all
excellent in it um what i found
fascinating though was that i looked at
the credits and it's like the smallest
credits i've seen on a movie in forever
so i'm just wondering were you guys like
also carrying lights and moving things
around yourself because it's like
it's not a big crew that made this yeah
we we definitely i mean there's pieces
of our furniture and artwork and jewelry
and beauty products and i mean we were
it was all hands on deck is to kind of
making
the environment
what we felt as the characters who would
be living there as well as producers we
were all producers on this as well so it
was an all hands on deck experience we
had incredible department heads but the
department heads were also the ones
doing the work of probably five people
that normally would be below them on any
other movie set so it really became
whoever was a necessity
was on set and that was such a small
amount of people
but it proves that you can do it and it
also created an environment that felt
the most
nurturing safe and collaborative for a
story like this and we also just kind of
became a it was like a summer a twisted
summer camp of sorts
at this location
you kind of
forget what it's like to do something
that's so streamlined and
it really it really opened my eyes you
know i've obviously done really small
movies but this one was so specific
because it was so contained so it could
be
extremely you know
streamlined
it just made me think you know
you
it's such a fun way of making a film
where no one is there to make any money
you know everyone is there
because they're interested in the
project and you know working with
charlie or you know whatever it is and
our crew was just so
efficient it was it was kind of
it was kind of crazy the amount of work
we were able to
fit into a day so if you have the right
people
uh the right crew you know
it's a very fun way to work
uh whose idea was it to have the easy
sneakers as your clothing device
clothing device
it was it was
mine a few days before
for some reason i mean that was a
slow strange process
piecing this character together
i had everything
and on the one hand i had birkenstocks
maybe with socks i think oh yeah i
remember that combo
and then i had i i don't know where it
came from but i guess just this thought
of of someone that although he's he's
very successful in this one field has
interests and you know
other other areas and really wants to be
cool and
you know accepted maybe in a different
scene you know
and so we kind of told enough of of that
or he's just trying but missing a mark
you know don't ask me why i said
clothing device no [ __ ] idea i don't
like it
i kind of love it it actually is though
it's it was clothing device the clothing
device
yeah i no idea so one of the things that
uh listen i love the movie three amigos
and this there's a scene of three amigos
in the movie and it plays because it's
funny but it also plays because it
really says a lot about the three
characters it's it's thematically
perfect for
the movie can you sort of talk about
like that aspect of it that was
charlie's number one choice for the
movie that they were watching um
and fought hard to get it
i think yeah it's it's comedic
obviously it's one of the greatest films
um but it's interesting to see how
nobody and wife connect over it while
ceo's doing
there's the element of the haves and the
have-nots and the ones that have the
most sometimes are the most unaware of
themselves and the wealth disparity
asset disparity all of that um but also
laced in this kind of
dark humor element which is very much
the movie that we filmed um it talked
about all those themes as well as having
this undertone of of dark comedy that
that leads to many different places
throughout the film but it did feel like
a
representation of these two people also
at the end watching this person who has
such an access
and be so unaware of himself and
it was it was thematically kind of right
on on point
on that note i gotta wrap i'm just gonna
say thank you so much for making a good
movie and i wish you guys nothing but
the best